-Welcome back
to "The Tonight Show."
We are here with one of
our favorites, John Cena!
[ Cheers and applause ]
In the studio with us with us,
John.
John and I are about to
face off in a new game
called "Toss It Over."
♪♪
♪ -Toss it over ♪
-Alright, here's how it works.
As you can see, John and I
have this wall between us.
Each of us will be given
four mystery items
that we have never seen before.
One at a time, we're going to
the mystery item over the wall,
and then it's the other player's
job to try and catch it.
But here's the thing.
Neither of us will know
what we're catching
until it's flying
right at our faces.
The person who can catch
the most items wins.
John, are you okay?
Can you hear me?
-I can, Jimmy!
-Wow.
[ Laughter ]
Feels like we're
doing a magic act.
We've never met before.
Is that correct?
Alright, alright, John,
you will be the first --
our first guest,
you'll catch first.
Are you ready for this?
-You damn right I will.
-I'm ready.
-Okay, alright, here we go.
Alright,
let's see the first item.
Okay, yeah. Alright.
[ Grunting ] Alright, dude. Ohh.
How do I pick this up?
-I'm eagerly waiting.
-How do I throw -- How do I
throw it? I don't know how to --
-I have a feeling
this is gonna be so fun.
[ Laughter ]
-It might get a little...
nasty!
[ Drumroll ]
[ Ding! ]
-[ Laughs ]
-Did he do it?
-Yes! Yes.
-Ah, it was a beach ball.
That was easy. That was easy.
-You're a good sport.
-Alright.
John, it is your turn to throw.
Here comes your item.
-Alright.
[ Drumroll ]
I have to [Grunts] navigate --
It's like like trying to
manipulate the Big Show.
Hold on.
Okay.
-Yeah.
-Are you ready, Jimmy?
-I hope so.
-In three --
-Ooh!
[ Laughter ]
[ Ding! ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
That counts, right?
That counts!
I like this dude.
Oh, my gosh.
I got to bring him to my girl.
Gosh, he's growling at me.
Alright.
Alright, it's my turn.
Let's see what I got this time.
Here we go.
[ Laughs ]
-I'm ready.
It's gonna be great.
Toss it over!
-[ Chuckles ]
Dude, this is serious.
Like, serious.
We had to have your agent
sign off on this.
[ Drumroll ]
Alright, buddy?
You just got to trust me
and just go for it, okay?
[ Grunting ] 1, 2, 3.
[ Grunts ]
[ Laughter ]
[ Buzzer ]
[ Laughs ]
Did he even try?
Did he try to get that?
Did he try? Are you okay?
-I am.
-Alright, good.
-A piece of me
died on the inside.
-Alright, alright, perfect.
-Thought you were throwing
a cinder block at me.
[ Laughter ]
That's fair. That's fair.
Alright, alright,
it's gonna be like that.
-Yeah, it's your turn.
Here we go.
-It's gonna be like that?
Okay, alright.
It's gonna be like that.
Alright, okay.
Alright then.
[ Drumroll ]
-Whenever you're ready.
-Oh, no, I'm ready.
The question is,
are you ready, Jimmy?
[ Rhythmic clapping ]
Anticipation builds.
-I can hear --
[ Laughter ]
[ Ding! ]
-Well worth it!
[ Laughter ]
Well -- I can't see you.
And I was slightly affected by
my throwing motion,
but it's well worth
whatever happened.
[ Laughter ]
-You want it back?
Gosh. Alright.
See, this is why
I didn't wear a suit.
[ Laughs ] Oh, my gosh.
Okay, let's see
what I'm throwing.
You're kidding me.
[ Laughter ]
-I'm gonna catch this.
-This is the --
This is insane.
-I'm going to catch this.
-Now I understand how you
agreed to do this game.
[ Laughter ]
Are you kidding me?
Alright, ready?
-Yes.
-[ Laughing ] 1, 2, 3.
[ Laughs ]
Sorry.
Sorry, John,
I threw the wrong one.
I'm sorry, John.
-What are you throwing over?
Oh, [bleep]!
[ Laughter ]
[ Ding! ]
-Yes!
-He got it? Alright. Good.
-Alright, John, it is your turn.
-[Bleep]
-I threw the wrong thing.
I apologize.
-I think we may have to
subtract some points
for throwing the wrong --
Was that -- Did you throw
my item over at me?
-No, no, no, that wasn't me.
That was --
-That was another pie?
Okay, fair.
-No, it was --
someone else ran in.
-It's dirty pool, Jimmy Fallon.
It's dirty pool.
Alright, alright.
-John, it's your turn.
-It is.
[ Drumroll ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
And away...we...go.
[ Laughter ]
[ Buzzer ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Stupidest game I have
ever played in my life.
[ Laughter ]
I mean, and I thought
"Fish Slap" was bad.
I thought "Fish Slap" was bad.
Alright, John, for this final --
Seriously, you got
a unicorn piñata.
[ Laughter ]
John, for this final round,
we're both going to throw
at the same time.
This is worth 1,000 points.
Let's see what
we'll be tossing over.
-A thous-- Okay, fair enough.
Fair enough.
-Yep.
Whoever wins this wins it all.
-Alright.
[ Drumroll ]
Throwing at the same time?
-Well, hold on a second.
[ Laughter ]
-Now, you said we're gonna be
throwing at the same time?
-What's that? Yes, we're
throwing at the same --
Do you want to count down
3 to 1?
-Yeah, or is it 1, 2, 3
or is it 3, 2, 1?
-Alright, I say it's 1 --
[ Laughs ]
-You say it's 1, 2, 3?
-It is 1...2...3.
[ Laughter ]
[ Ding! ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah!
-That was for you.
-Eww!
-That was for you!
-Ah!
-He caught it.
Alright, good,
then I got to say the winner --
Then I must say the winner --
[ Laughter ]
The winner is [Laughs]
John Cena, everybody!
-How? How do I win?
[ Dinging ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Stick around!